hello and welcome to this video playing
Mata bollocks I'm going you fall again I
usually battle and jay king's indian
word i'm currently trying to do a little
bit check and play some different
openings probably form here sure about
to move over here i try to avoid the
early simplifications that are possible
sometimes in this line and I've got the
maroc see buying set up there often have
just a little bit to get different here
is six as the light squared bishops are
traded interesting guys out to play be
firm be five
b5 and camera very quickly plate hmm I
thought yeah it's probably it's probably
nothing a 95 queen d 2 y is equal yeah
yeah anyway let's play it
it's very equal yeah I'm just trying out
some opening lines and sometimes I just
get get nowhere Bishop I'm sorry Quinn
txt to it's just the move and then night
XD five it should be completely ok for
black and 95 °c takes and it's it's
equal ok I didn't expect this move 93
however makes an awful lot of sensor ok
probably I I don't have much more which
is I understand kind of boring I cannot
allow a 93 and give him give them the C
file somehow ok I have a slight
advantage in space it should be um in
any way important but yeah we can try
not to be four would be good if I could
get that end but not sure that I can
easily do that if I go f4 to kick that
nite 45 I'm weakening my structure quite
a bit okie for ok is immediately going
for this getting rid of some of the
space issue ok so he wants to get to an
IQ p position let's do it it's
completely ok Howie how is playing this
it's perfectly okay that i QP isn't the
problem him at all
so is that a way to get the night over
to those pawns if I go f4 is going
knight c6 again it's not a biggie big
issue actually 94 is not helping him a
lot like 96 93 94 and it's not a big
problem or any problem
okay now night c5 is going a five I
guess I wonder if that actually helps I
think this is probably better and
improving this first Bishop to c5 and I
don't think he wants to go deform this
is probably not a great idea he I have a
for fixing this on a dark square okay
okay gain a bit of space it's very
likely a draw but let's play it anyway
he wants to invade here d 5 C 4 and so
on hmm
yeah it gets to see for huh that's a bit
of an issue maybe he gets them not
completely sure okay so I need to get
this pawn going maybe Bishop before is
the trick No ok so f 6 or night f4 is
going to e four so this is not good
time morning okay
I'm going to get them I see five now and
sorry get d for now I'm a little bit
quicker with the a porn so maybe he can
probably just yep its unfortunately a
draw our third yeah I know it's a draw
but for those who are skeptical I'm
going to show and wide as a draw check
check check check check check the
problem always is that he goes into the
corner check and like him it's a
stalemate and I have no way of doing
this if I somewhat give him a square and
he escapes and again he's threatening to
promote it so it's just a draw I usually
would accept it but to show it on the
board yeah probably nothing ever
happened here I thought maybe I have
slight chances here but probably added
something wrong maybe it is just a draw
all the way needles thought maybe Bishop
c5 is probably better yeah I should
probably do this so that I'm ready to
step to you for if he decides to go d 4
which would be wrong I guess ya hear I'm
very slightly by
but it's a draw you here had some met
some issues but probably this is just
about what needs to be done to draw the
game now carry here the computer says
I'm winning no allow it corrects itself
that should be a draw really there's
nothing to do any justice in time here
to get to this drawing position probably
I have to play the opening a bit
differently but I just not an expert
down yeah this is this is probably I
can't do much more it's just totally
equal yeah I have to improve on that
opening to to get something okay well
thanks for watching